International charter and commercial
flights are allowed to start flying into
the capital of the Philippines again now
flights to Manila were temporarily
banned to free up quarantine facilities
after tens of thousands of workers
returned home from overseas
our correspondent Jamila Allen Dogen is
at the airport in Manila and the partial
opening of the airport will bring some
relief to well passengers and also to
the business community
well definitely saw a lemon we've seen
how it basically crippled a major
industry here in the Philippines and as
you know for the last few hours we've
been here we've been speaking to foreign
nationals a majority of them are
actually those who are departing our
foreign nationals students tourists who
were stranded here for weeks they talked
about feeling relief that they're able
to go back home and basically a majority
of them have been waiting for access to
flight today last week the government
immediately halted incoming commercial
flights because of the congested
congestion of quarantine facilities
because of the arrival of tens of
thousands of overseas Filipino workers
and this is expected again to continue
over the next few weeks while the
lockdown and of course the pandemic
continues now according to aviation
officials here
despite the reopening of incoming
flights passengers are limited to about
400 a day that is because that is the
current capacity of the Manila Airport
under this lockdown so hail